Dr. Seymour Tracy is an ordinary American
man.
He lives in a two-bedroom home with a white
picket fence, in an ordinary suburban town
in the midwest.
He gets up every day and goes to work, then
in the evening, he comes home to spend time
with his family.
From the outside, Seymour and his family couldn't
be more normal.
But in reality, there's something very abnormal
about him, his life, and the neighbourhood
where he lives.
Seymour Tracy isn't just some office worker,
he's a researcher employed by the SCP Foundation,
just like all of his neighbours.
Because this isn't an ordinary neighbourhood
- it's a functioning Site 11 satellite facility,
bought and maintained by the Foundation for
the sole purpose of containing and monitoring
a single SCP: SCP-3082.
SCP-3082 is an ordinary treehouse, 2 meters
by 2 meters in size and built from ordinary
cherry wood planks, and it’s located in
one of the trees in the neighbourhood park.
You might expect that an anomaly that requires
an entire suburb of people to monitor it is
exceptionally difficult to contain, but the
truth is, SCP-3082 is only a Euclid class
anomaly, fairly tame by Foundation standards.
The fact that the houses surrounding this
SCP are inhabited solely by Foundation personnel
and their families is, more than anything,
a way to keep up appearances of this being
a completely normal neighbourhood.
Unlike most Foundation sites, the personnel
working in this unorthodox setup around SCP-3082
are mostly researchers, and their work is
just as much anthropological and diplomatic
as it is scientific.
As you might have guessed, SCP-3082 isn't
a normal treehouse on the inside - open up
the small hatch in the wall and step through,
and you'll find yourself in a much larger,
grander treehouse, that rests on the upper
branches of an absolutely massive conifer-like
tree of an unidentified species.
The tree, designated as SCP-3082-1, is an
incredible 160 kilometers tall, and, while
its own species is not known, it appears to
have multiple recognizable plants grafted
onto and growing out of its bark.
Many of these plants are fruit-bearing, and
in addition to the identifiable plants, there
are also a number of pitcher plant-like flowers
that collect and hold fresh water.
These plants serve as sustenance for the only
known inhabitants of SCP-3082 - a colony of
around 74 children, all between the ages of
4 and 12.
These children live in a village made up of
other treehouses built among the branches
of SCP-3082-1, and all of them match the descriptions
of children from around the United States
who went missing between 1996 and the present
day.
Curiously, within SCP-3082's pocket dimension,
the children don't physically age, and while
Foundation personnel can move freely back
and forth through the hatch in SCP-3082's
wall, children under the age of 13 are unable
to cross back through once inside the pocket
dimension.
It’s a very extraordinary anomaly, but it
was up to the very ordinary Dr. Tracy to make
contact with the residents of SCP-3082.
Upon entering, he discovered that the children
had formed their own system of government,
known as the Chief Royal Council.
Dr. Tracy was introduced to many of the council's
members, including Wexley Olson, age 6, a
junior council member.
Lucy Fujimoto, age 7, who had taken the role
of city planner and resource manager.
Ahmed Sayid, age 11, who served as a caretaker
to the younger citizens of SCP-3082, and Rachel
Jeffreys, age 10, who acted as a council mediator.
Through interviews with the subjects, Dr.
Tracy found that all 74 of the children reported
that they had woken up on the porch of a treehouse
after running away from troubled homes.
Most of the council members had disappeared
in 1996, except for Olson, who disappeared
in 2005.
Older residents report that some of the treehouses
that make up what is now their village were
already there upon their discovery of the
pocket dimension.
Also pre-existing within the pocket dimension
was the original leader of the Chief Royal
Council - a 12 year old girl from Ohio named
Aria Morison.
The Foundation was eager to speak to Morison,
as she was seemingly the first child to discover
SCP-3082, but when Dr. Tracy asked the other
children where she was, they told him that
they didn't know.
According to Sayid and Jeffreys, Morison abandoned
the colony 5 months before the Foundation's
arrival.
It was unclear where she could have gone,
as drone exploration conducted by the Foundation
revealed that SCP-3082-1 was the only large
living thing for miles within the pocket dimension.
While the tree was thriving, the surrounding
area was mostly flat, decaying, and barren.
Further research into Morison's history showed
that her younger sister, Jaquelyn Morison,
had also gone missing on the same night, but
there was no evidence that Jaquelyn had ever
entered SCP-3082.
The Foundation continued their research into
the biology of SCP-3082-1, while maintaining
diplomatic relations with the pocket dimension's
citizens.
Taking advantage of the fact that adults could
move freely in and out of the hatch, the Foundation
started working with the Chief Royal Council
to improve the weight limits on the village's
system of rope bridges, as well as providing
any supplies that the children might need,
such as additional food, clothing and medical
equipment.
These liaisons were extremely helpful for
the children, many of whom had been without
any adult supervision or care for over a decade.
Sayid, for one example, had fallen off of
a bridge and broken his leg several years
earlier, and had been living with the pain
caused from the bone being incorrectly set
ever since.
However, there was an unexpected side effect
of this continued contact.
While the Foundation tried to remain neutral
in their involvement in the politics of 3082,
through Dr. Tracy's interviews, he discovered
that the SCP Foundation's presence in the
treehouse had caused a schism within the Chief
Royal Council.
The vast majority of the children, including
Sayid, Jeffreys and Fujimoto, supported the
Foundation's presence and wanted to work with
them to find a way to leave the world of 3082
and return back to what the children called
'the real world'.
But a splinter group had developed, calling
themselves the Neverland Movement.
The Neverland Movement were angered by the
Foundation's interference and intended to
resist any attempt to return the children
to civilization.
Olson had become the de-facto leader of the
splinter group, and made no secrets about
his views on the Foundation.
He swore at Tracy during interviews, and frequently
butted heads with the rest of the council,
Fujimoto in particular.
At one point, Tracy overheard the two of them
fighting, with Olson arguing that Neverland
gives them everything they need without any
grown-ups to tell them what to do and that
they would be stupid to give that up.
To which Fujimoto responded- “I was here
back when we were still building the village.
I was here before we had safety nets, ladders,
and fences and before we figured out how to
build a tree house that wouldn't fall apart
if someone leaned on a bad wall.
I was here before we knew where there was
more food if we needed it.
When did you get here, huh?
...After we knew what we were doing.”
Listening to the conversation, Dr. Tracy heard
the children refer again to Aria Morison in
a way that suggested that she had some kind
of control over the environment.
In reference to the incident when Sayid had
broken his leg, Fujimoto said “Mary didn't
fix his leg right and this place didn't fix
it either.
Aria prayed, and you know what happened?
Nothing!”
From this comment, the Foundation started
to theorize that Aria had somehow been involved
in the creation of SCP-3082, and Aria was
officially designated as SCP-3082-2.
One morning, when Dr. Tracy entered the treehouse
and walked through the hatch to conduct further
interviews, he was greeted by Olson, who was
the only child in the main treehouse at the
time.
Tracy asked what was wrong, and Olson explained
that the tree had started to change - a wooden
slide had appeared between two of the tree's
fruit-bearing branches, snapping the rope
bridge and making the fruit more difficult
to access.
On top of that, Olson said that the apples
the trees produced were different now - they
looked like apples from the outside, but now
seemed to be made of cotton candy on the inside.
Dr. Tracy put in a request for non-perishable
foods to be sent through into the pocket dimension,
fearing that further changes to the tree's
structure would mean the children would be
deprived of enough proper nutrition to survive.
Given these changes, it became apparent that
more had to be done to understand the tree's
physiology.
An exploratory drone was sent into the dimension,
with cameras and sensors collecting data on
the lower parts of the tree that the children
hadn't colonized.
The expedition continued as normal, until
the drone operators spotted a hollow in the
tree that had not yet been documented.
The cameras detected movement inside the hollow,
and on closer inspection, the operators were
shocked to find that it was a person.
More specifically, it was Aria Morison.
The cameras were only just able to confirm
her identity, though, as the drone was knocked
out of the sky by a falling watermelon and
the feed was cut.
Before the request for a replacement drone
could even be approved, though, the broken
drone started transmitting again.
In front of the camera was Morison, clutching
a roll of duct tape.
She explained to the camera that she'd rewired
the drone to resume the camera feed and removed
some of the drone's fan blades.
Using a system where the operators of the
drone would rotate the remaining blades once
for yes and twice for no, the Foundation was
able to hold a conversation with Morison.
She confirmed much of the information that
the Foundation already had on her, that she
was from Ohio, and that she and her sister
Jacquelyn had disappeared in 1996.
During the conversation, Morison wrote down
a morse code-like system through which to
communicate more complex questions and answers,
and with the help of this 'Morison code',
the Foundation was able to conduct a series
of more in depth interviews with the subject.
The first interview occurred 44 hours after
first making contact, and the drone operators
explained to her the nature of the SCP Foundation
in basic terms.
They assured her that the other children were
still safe in the village, but Morison didn't
volunteer any more information about herself.
9 days later though, she finally told the
Foundation her story.
Aria and Jacquelyn Morison had a difficult
childhood together - their parents fought
constantly and would often leave the sisters
at home without supervision for long periods
of time.
Jacquelyn, perhaps aided by all the time she
spent alone, displayed an extremely active
imagination.
So active, in fact, that Aria claimed she
was able to pull things out of thin air, warping
reality around her to fit her imagined scenarios.
Aria recalled that one year,when the Morison
parents had forgotten Jacquelyn's birthday,
Aria tried to comfort her by saying that the
family had been planning a surprise party
for Jacquelyn's half birthday instead.
She forgot all about her white lie until 6
months later when the girls' parents took
them to the park and everything Aria had told
Jacquelyn would be at her half-birthday was
there waiting for them.
Knowing the potential consequences of letting
Jacquelyn's power go unchecked, Aria always
made sure to remind her sister to turn things
back to normal after they played pretend together.
One night in 1996, while their parents were
having a particularly bad fight, the sisters
packed a bag and ran off into the woods.
After about half an hour, they got turned
around, but they kept walking, just as afraid
of what would happen to them if they went
back home as they were of being lost in the
woods.
Aria lost track of Jacquelyn for a moment,
and suddenly found herself standing on the
porch of SCP-3082.
Unable to find Jacquelyn anywhere, Aria searched
the treehouse, and in the process, became
trapped in SCP-3082's pocket dimension.
The treehouse inside the pocket dimension
appeared exactly as it does now, but the rest
of the tree was devoid of life.
Scared, alone, and running out of water, Aria
sat in the treehouse and, pretending that
her sister was with her, started telling a
bedtime story about fruit trees and pitchers
of fresh water.
The next day, she awoke to find a system of
rope bridges and a grove where SCP-3082-1's
fruit-bearing trees and pitcher plants had
sprouted overnight.
Aria found that, when it was in a giving mood,
the tree would respond to any requests she
made.
More children started to appear over time,
and they started making additions to the village,
with the tree's help.
They would get what they needed to survive,
but the tree refused to let them go.
In Aria Morison's own words- “Jacquelyn
likes it too much here in Neverland.
I think Jackie might listen better if I get
closer to the part of her that remembers,
but for now… she doesn't hear me when I
say that it's time to go home.
Trees don't really think like people do.”
And so the children continue to live in the
world of SCP-3082 to this day as a whole town
of SCP Foundation personnel work to bring
them back.
And hopefully if they are able to return to
the real world, they’ll find that it’s
the world they deserve.
Now go check out “SCP - 087 - The Staircase”
and “SCP - 096 - The Shy Guy” for more
and don’t forget to subscribe and turn on
notifications to be the first to learn about
the fascinating files from the SCP Foundation.